as of guys my name is Chan oh and
welcome to another vlog type deal that I
keep doing sometimes but probably not
very often and this is going to be my
love them dare I'm in kind of video that
I do every time if all of them day you
guys are probably going to guess what
this video is about it's a lot of there
is this weekend but basically i will be
doing let them there this weekend it
starts saturday i don't even know when
it starts to be honest i think it's
around midday for me but like 1pm
probably i'm not actually on a percent
sure which is great but um it's going to
start on Saturday if you guys want to
count down as to when it will start for
you then just go to love and calm and
you'll see a countdown timer right on
the side and you'll be able to see when
that starts so first of all what is like
them there for those of you who do not
know still soul atom dare is a 48-hour
game programming competition or a 72 72
hour game jam in which you have 48 hours
or 772 hours to make a game from scratch
based on an on the theme that gets
released at the beginning of the
competition so you can use whatever
tools you so as chairs very squeaky
anyway you can use whatever tools you
wish to make a game be that actually
make it from scratch using something
like C++ or Java or use an engine like
unreal on unity and you can make you can
use whatever technology you like you can
make game for whatever platform you like
and at the end the people who submitted
games which is usually around 2,000
people also they will vote on each
other's games and thus a winner will be
decided and you don't really win
anything you just win the fact that
you've won right that's that's it it's
just one of those you know let's do this
for fun kind of things so i'll be
streaming the whole thing on twitch.tv
force after cherno like I do every time
and I like you guys know by now that
every latum dare I use a different
technology okay last time i use sparky
the time before that I used WebGL and
JavaScript to the first time before that
I used I think lwjgl but like modern
OpenGL I think and then before that I
use legacy OpenGL explicitly anyway I
always use different technologies
because I don't see that I'm there as I
let's make an awesome game I more or
less see it as hey I've got a weekend to
learn something new ok I am probably
going to eventually take it more
seriously but for now I'm just like I've
got a list of things i wish i knew and
this is like a weekend in which i can
actually learn that technology so for me
that's I'm sorry microphone for me
that's more beneficial right so that's
kind of what I do so this time I'm going
to use something that I've never used
before to make a game and that is unity
ok now I feel a little bit dirty using
unity I have to say just because I'm
always so let's make stuff from scratch
guy and I really enjoy low-level
programming graphics programming and all
that stuff and unity kind of takes that
all away from me because like making
game entrance is what I do right it's
what i like is it's my passion so when
the game ends has already done for me
it's like well you know is making the
game even that fun like I didn't like
making engines but anyway I'm that being
said i will use unity this done now
there are two reasons for doing that one
I well three reasons actually the first
one is I actually want to make a game
that is more about making the game and
less about making the engine why because
I feel like there have been too many
years since since I made a game that was
actually good in fact the last game that
I actually still consider good the game
I made last long day shift I found that
quite fun to be honest so I will qualify
that as an actual video game and then I
think the time before that was Genesis
like that is that that was my first love
until under 24 that was the last time I
think that I actually made a game in
which i call it at a game a game which
you could play and not just some kind of
test or something but an actual game
that i enjoyed right it's been too long
i really want to make a game but also so
that's risen one right let's actually
maybe focus on the gameplay and actually
maybe make a game right that's that's
the first deal second deal is I want to
learn unity because I've never used
unity and unity is a bit like it's a
good thing to know because a lot of
people always compare things to unity
and I think it's just really important
to
you know more and more technologies and
what not and you know I mean that should
be fun anyway learning unity on the fly
it's how I could be i mean its unity and
then the third reason third reason is
because i'm doing a bit of covert
intelligence gathering I want to
investigate how unity does a few things
and then basically put them into Sparky
okay so Sparky is the game mention that
i'm making for those of you don't know
and that will eventually have you know
an editor and all that stuff and I think
it's obviously a good idea to use an
editor to better understand how how like
how I might come up with a way to put
that into Sparky and how I might come up
with Sparky's editor and workflow as
well so that's why I really want to do a
bit of bit of sneaky
intelligence-gathering to take a look at
unity and and see exactly how it handles
things because i'm actually i'm just
interested in that right okay so more
specifics unity how much have unity have
i used i have i have used unity before
and by that i mean i've downloaded i've
installed it and i've spent five minutes
sessions in it until I'm like dude like
I want to go back to C++ or something
like that so I haven't really used it
I've used it in my entire life I've used
unity for a collective amount of about
four hours I would say I've put a block
down I've added a physics Collider I've
written a script and I've hit play and
I've been like well that was completely
unsatisfying and that's it okay now not
bashing unity by the way I think it is a
wonderful tool is it's really probably
the only way you can make a game if
you're a solo indie developer and you
want to make a 3d am that is quite
complex I think that you would be
probably a bit foolish not to use
something like unity because there is no
way you're going to be able to write an
engine by yourself especially if you
don't have too much experience if you
have a team of engineers then I would
absolutely right an engine but you know
if you're an indie developer who wants
to get that game out and wants to
actually ship a game unity is a
very very good choice but anyway the
point is this video is not about unity
and game engines and shipping games and
all that all that stuff but the point is
that I that's all I've done in unity
right I've just I've done that and I've
that's it I haven't actually made any
games in UD ever I have never finished a
game I don't actually know how to use
unities what I'm trying to say so I will
be learning it on the fly what I think I
might do is actually record the entire
session and then post it on YouTube I
try to do that last time unfortunately
didn't record it recorded my wrong if it
recorded the wrong monitor right so I
was sure I was trimming this monitor and
then it recorded the wrong miser so that
was a big problem and I don't actually
have no idea how I managed that because
in the preview I'm pretty sure it showed
my main monitor anyway this time I'm
going to do that and I might pose the
whole thing to youtube and I might title
at something like let's learn unity
whilst making a game to let them down or
something ridiculous so that you guys
can see how I approach new technologies
and how I learned stuff on the fly and
maybe because I'll trying to rate this a
lot because I figure I'll have so much
free time because unity is going to be
so much easier to make a game in Europe
than in well last time Sparky or from
scratch that i'm going to have so much
time so I'll just narrate it and i'll
talk about it and i'll kind of be able
to probably make a better game as well
in fact definitely i should be able to
make a better game um so yeah now i
don't have unity pro or anything so
there is going to be a splash screen in
front of my game but that's okay i might
hack it to make the dark theme up here
though just because i don't want to be
found at a light theme but anyway all
that aside that that's the plan that's
going to happen this weekend so if you
are excited to watch me learn unity on
the fly and make a game for Adam dad
then head over to twitch.tv for slasher
know there will be a link in the
description to that and and the yeah
that's this weekend so i'll be streaming
for most of the 48 hours i would imagine
and of course for those of you who are
interested as well i will be composing
the music again to mike game to my
hopefully good game this time and i will
live streamed out as well in fact i'm
trying to set up an actual camera in my
studio instead of this
count so that I can capture that a bit
better because I know a lot of people
are really interested in that and yes so
i'll definitely require that and i'll
definitely post the unedited me making
music video to youtube this time as well
I didn't do that last time but I will
this time and it should all work out
really well so I'm really excited I'm
gonna have some fun we're gonna make a
game and hopefully you guys in the chat
will be like hey man this is not how you
make this immunity you should do this
instead because yeah so let's let's do
that and I will see you guys this
weekend goodbye wool